dana white is had a
huge thing he's been losing his mind
i'm going to go ahead and just uh play
the play the interview instead of
there's an article to it we'll get to
the article too but um
illegal streaming is a big issue for the
ufc
you know guys we like to joke around on
that slide show but i'll tell you what's
not a laughing matter
illegal streaming you wouldn't download
a house would you i would have yeah i
mean you could you could get a 3d
printer technically
nowadays so that doesn't even make sense
right you could download it you wouldn't
download a metallic album would you
yeah of course not their new stuff no
everything up to 1994. you go even
further than i do but i even give you
that that's not bad no they were good up
to 98. they were
still a good band in 90. so
there's listen i don't know who i i look
apparently they made like
70 million dollars just on this fight
uh with people buying the pay-per-view
now the thing with this pay-per-view is
i have never ever ever watched one of
these and paid for it
no i i'm trying to think i'm like no
either two things happen
one you go to a bar that has it on
two you get someone okay hey what's the
streaming on and they just tell you hey
check it out stream over here you go to
the website
you got a link yeah so dana white's not
happy about that he's also not happy
being on trt and hgh and his face
his jaw bones are getting big because of
the hgh um
but you don't like uh you don't like the
fact that dana white's slowly morphing
into michael chiklis
not really that could be something
special
just to finish up the big challenge is
um why does every mma guy selling
speaking i don't know like every
commentator nowadays i mean it's like uh
tell me about your fight with monkey i
gotta
and this guy's from queens that's very
weird super weird
something special just to finish up the
big challenges
um of 2021 i've seen you speaking
about piracy uh obviously this i'm so
glad you asked me this question well we
are
i'm so glad you you you wrote you've
asked the question that was
pre-written down for you by my people
i'm so glad that you chose to do the
thing i told you to do
this is that i'm so glad you asked me
this question this goes off at the
weekend
on uh vt sport box office we have those
issues
as well how would you solve that in the
modern world
so now before he answers mike
i always like to do this like to get a
reasonable answer how would what would
you do if i said that to you if i go
look yeah you know you have this ufc
thing it's doing great
piracy is an issue like how would you
solve it in the modern world
i would say you know look i
i think that we as a company should
probably
do whatever other company does and
enforce our copyrights
but i mean people are just they're going
to stream it anyway
yeah but uh i don't know i i would just
uh hope that people who enjoy this fine
sport
uh would like to um pay for the service
that we deliver i don't know something
like that well what i would mine would
be
you know i do hear maybe we should
change the model from being
seventy dollars for a pay-per-view to do
what other companies do where you get a
month you know
pay a monthly fee to get all the ufc
fights you know and that includes the
pay-per-views like what wwe did you know
you could play the w network and you get
all the pay-per-views
maybe something like that he should have
said that
this is what he is we've been working on
piracy since day one it's one of the
things that
that we focused on one of the reasons we
bought an island was because we wanted
to actually start being pirates
they told me there were doubloons on
that island and i wanted to find them i
don't know
we got rogan got us all really high and
one day we were like what if we were
just pirates dude
and like i'll buy an island and then i
just had this island i don't know what
to do with it
so i started having fights on it i guess
yeah i said like what if we what if we
had a pirate island and then joe rogan
said well that just blew my [ __ ] mind
and then i was like wow if joe's
impressed so i
dropped like 2 billion on an island why
do you not have an island
how would you solve that in the modern
world so
we've been working on piracy since day
one it's one of the things that
that we focused on and we've looked in
like certain law enforcement strategies
even like we've spoke we've hired like a
consultancy firm
uh and they had advised us uh to find
out who's
streaming these things and then find
their wives and stick a gun in their
was he a [ __ ] we hired uh we hired some
like former new york law enforcement
people oh
it just came in okay it was one of the
things that
that we focused on uh you know
it's an important thing to stop in this
business
so we've spent tons of money and all
this stuff so i
we we just got some real important
legislature done
with piracy he's not a smart man
he's not legislation done first off
you're not on the government if you're
implying that you have that you're
paying people off from the government
that's one thing
but nope no one's ever gone and i
gavel gavel gavel gavel and i'm gonna
introduce the dana
white bill into congress
trump would have done that right because
i want to be cool called the dana white
bill
and all this stuff so i we just got some
real
important legislature done with piracy
this year so when i came out and said
that
you have all these these people are
criminals
you know and and the internet you know
makes it look like these guys are good
guys right because
you you don't you don't you don't have
any criminals that fight for you right
yeah didn't you
didn't you didn't connor have like a
really shady deal like they let him off
real light
like didn't you spread a lot of money
around her in that whole incident
and i mean don't you have don't you have
people fight for you that used to beat
their wives up
still do still do people that get drunk
and drive and do cocaine and
didn't you give uh didn't you give a
what's his face like jon jones like 37
tries
after he kept just [ __ ] doing drugs
you know and and the internet you know
makes it look like these guys are good
guys
they are compared to the people that
fight for you
yeah most of them make no money doing it
either so it's like
to pretend that they're like these
nefarious criminals when in fact they're
like usually it's a thankless shitty job
to run these streams
yeah it's like some this guy think it's
someone with a guy fox mask
sitting there it's anonymous you know it
makes it look like these guys are good
guys
these guys are bad guys and what they i
would argue that the person charging
70 to watch a fight is probably the bad
guy in the situation
am i the bad guy here what they do is a
lot of these guys
will put up these links and say hey you
know
check out we'll give it to you for free
and all this stuff and they steal your
information
but so do you
so does your espn plus where you stream
your fights
they also steal your information that's
different bro it's a company
that actually makes it worse it's
awesome
then i get targeted ads yeah but they
take your yeah but they take your
information and then pay me money and i
can fly private so
it's better i'm on duck tales larry
you know number one
number two when i came out and said this
all these
guys started taunting me yes
because it's hilarious because it's one
of the funniest things you've ever done
you
because you showed that it bothers you
and now you're going to
quadruple down now there's going to be
more streams than ever yeah
so i went through and i picked i said
you you you're the guy
and i told him he thinks he's a mob boss
he really does
he thinks he's a mob boss my people i
want this guy
and guess what we got
is he dead did you kill him well
technically i don't have him wait to
hear this
we're watching his house we're listening
to his phone conversations
it seems illegal that sounds highly
illegal
that's stalking and wiretapping if i'm
correct
that's that's what are you you're doing
what now you're committing
several fellow federal crimes crimes
what are you doing
and guess what we got
we got him we're watching him let me
tell you something last night
okay i snuck into his house while him
and his wife were asleep oh no
i pulled her tampon out and swapped it
out while they were asleep
that's how [ __ ] look at me it's how
close i am dude it's just like
those all sound like crimes dana
what we got
we got him i broke into his house last
night
right walked right up to his dog while
it was sleeping
and just smacked it in the face as hard
as i could
and it woke up and looked at me and
yelped and then i just left
that dog knows he's all smelling
crunches
what are you what are you doing in their
house last night
i went into the refrigerator and i made
a sandwich
like okay dana you can't did you wipe
the prince down at least
i sent him the name of his kid's teacher
do you imagine that you like you wake up
and he's just sitting in the chair in
your bedroom like eating a sandwich and
you're like what the [ __ ] dana white
stop streaming my [ __ ] and you're like
okay i feel like my streaming your [ __ ]
though right now is the least of your
concerns
you've just committed multiple a battery
of felony offenses
we're listening to his phone
conversations and when he puts up this
if he puts it up on saturday i'm gonna
kill his grandmother
and by the way this was the most
transparent bluff i've ever heard in my
life
so this was his way of going it could be
see it could be any one of you guys it
could be any one of you guys that were
lit
he's not trying to transcribe him tactic
but it's this is like
the [ __ ] doesn't work dana it doesn't
work on the internet
you're you're doing the thing that
parents used to do when they bluff
they go oh and by the way no parties
because i'm going to have
people driving by the house and they're
going to let me know if you got it and
you're like you did not make all of it
no one's doing this
i'm having a party as soon as you leave
we got him
he pops this link up on saturday we got
him
and we will arrest him we will arrest
the ufc is a law enforcement apparatus
same thing
the ufc police force is going to arrest
him
what is it retired fighters all right is
crow cop going to show up
royce lopez hi detective ken fresno i'm
with the uh ufc
detectives agency wait what
you're gonna leave my house now
[ __ ] but what if it's all just
retired fighters
i got him we know who he is and if you
stream this thing on saturday we're
gonna
dana white just did the online piracy
equivalent of when you put like an adt
sign on your house but you don't
actually pay for the service
yep you just hope the sign scares people
off
somebody michael b is like the ufc
police is a cop and a singlet
and why why are they having this in the
in the [ __ ] air lounge
the sky lounge delta delta sky lounge
it does we got them
and we will arrest them you can't arrest
them first of all because you're a
private company secondly
um does does he understand that like
90 of these online streamers are in like
belarus
well he gets into that okay so mike i'm
sorry you thought this was just a u.s
crime he was committing
no no this is an international crime oh
okay he's an international man of
mystery yeah
saturday we got him and we will arrest
him
and i will prosecute him you will
probably wait are you going to be the
attorney
leading the prosecution because i would
have i think he's going to end up
walking yeah
hey your honor let me [ __ ] this guy in
his [ __ ] ass what do you say like
dude you should really hire attorneys
for this
i will not be nice i will not give him
any leniency whatsoever
i will go guns are [ __ ] blazing
he really like this is what happens when
you have these like
this [ __ ] megalomaniac like
description of
grandeur yeah like he really thinks he's
a like he is a guy
that has probably done some drugs in a
hotel room and jerked off and looked in
the mirror and was like i'm a
[ __ ] god you know what i mean like
he's one of those guys he just comes off
that way
i have a particular set of skills it's
on the phone
i'm not like these [ __ ] losers down
there in the lobby i'm a [ __ ]
god i'm the giant like he's one of those
guys you can tell
you're jaws giant from that hgh calm
down oh jesus
is that just american legislation or are
you looking to try and do that worldwide
as worldwide
oh okay cool go past those laws in china
my friend
no no no go pass your little copyright
rules in
china first off it's okay dana white you
give me bag of money i chain
everybody to a desk hey dana you [ __ ]
most of these people are using like
three vpns that are streaming this
they're not just streaming from their
account they're streaming with three
vpns
and they're all routing through china
what are you gonna do
this guy isn't in america it's that in
america
look at the smile listen guess what but
guess what
i'm not some bitch-ass local american
cop
ufc has jurisdiction around the world
really
wait what this guy's not american
listen this is big because hey listen
these guys think they're
these guys think they're so smart they
think they're untouchable they're
smarter than you
yeah they are smart i mean i know you
built a big business but really you just
got you know he didn't build the big
business no you he bought a big boat but
what i'm saying is
he bought it back when it was in trouble
right and you got some
you know money behind you and you you
did your thing but like
calm down dana your name's dana you're a
man
named dana these guys think they're so
smart
they think they're untouchable they
think it's impossible
when when when you have a company is big
and it's
if the nfl wanted to kill did you see
what he was going to say as
big in his power he was going to say
powerful but you saw him stop himself
possible when when you have a company as
big
and as if the nfl wanted to catch people
for doing it if
that they can catch you no they can't i
could
i have i could watch red zone in every
game all year
with like 300 different streams yeah you
know what happens the stream goes down
and the same guys put up a new stream
and they're like here it's over here now
and that's it
you can be caught the guy just has to be
as sick as me
and want to get sick oh yeah bro he's so
sick oh [ __ ] he's so
he's so sick he's such a sick [ __ ] bro
oh god look i'm not even saying i get
protecting your copyright i
even understand that but but this
[ __ ] grandiose [ __ ]
bro you're not [ __ ] sick like me bro
i'm [ __ ] sick dude
you wanna get next let's get like like
michael keaton and batman
breaking a lamp you're a forty something
year old man get a grip on you
relax dana reuter age isn't a good look
on you buddy
get you okay and we got you buddy
this guy puts this link up on saturday
night
he's mine i think it's important for
people to understand but like so i want
to ask right because i didn't watch the
fight
but i'm gonna assume that it was
probably really hard to watch that fight
right like there was
probably more streams up than ever no
yeah
wow it's almost it's almost like the
internet heard dana white
and then just spitefully did whatever
they wanted
yeah there was actually more uh up than
normal
and on top of that uh one one of the
streamers um
this guy's a hero i obviously won't i
won't even out who the guy is because i
really don't
don't want him to get in trouble because
dana white would [ __ ] do something
stupid
like this but one of the streamers uh
decided to
while they were doing intermissions put
up memes making fun of dana white
on his illegal stream so this is the
fight going on here
and then he was putting haha don't care
[ __ ] memes
of data white on the screen so the
entire
internet turns out was making fun of him
for example
uh the internet did this white versus
streamers january 23rd
but and only that his own fighters were
making fun of him look at derrick lewis
hey me and dana white want to know
who's streaming tonight it's one of his
fighters
dana white finding out finding out i'm
streaming fights on youtube
oh my gosh i like that it's a tna kurt
angle clip too
dana white going undercover like this
tonight to catch those illegal streamers
hilarious this guy's the hero this guy
actually
streamed a logan paul fight off the
reflection in his class i remember that
one that's yeah that's an old-school one
uh dana seeing all the legal streams are
still up
uh dana white has been so here's what
happened
i call it karma call it whatever a lot
of people's feeds that paid for the
fight
went down an error occurred we're trying
to connect to our servers
please try again yeah uh
again so a lot of people like oh did you
take down this stream
uh somebody says dana is inside my house
guys what the [ __ ] help
entrapment my best friend who doesn't
even watch you if she suddenly asked me
for an illegal stream
nice try dana
what happened guys he is like they're
not taking you seriously mr white
he is getting annihilated on the
internet right now
what in a like [ __ ] people like dana
white
are like this like relic
left over from like rap rock days
you know i mean like he's like i'm
laughing because i know exactly what you
mean
he's russ hanneman from i was about to
say it he's frozen he really is
part of the mud you ever heard of him
[Music]
you know he's that guy i want doors to
go like this
now like this you know what he's just
like you know like
he's he's living proof that like you
could have all the money in the world
and just still be
a complete douchebag
he is rusty incurable being a douchebag
oh [ __ ] christ uh he has a signed uh
hot dog flavored water [ __ ] cd in his
house
vinyl it was a limited print bro